- [Praveen] Excellent.
Folks, I just wanna start off by saying,
well, Justin and I were quite
nervous, as you can imagine,
but seeing you all here bright and early,
15 minutes before the
session started means a lot.
So just wanted to say thank you so much
for being here so early
and hopefully, we can do justice
for the time you've
invested in us, all right?
Just on that note, I wanna
do a quick raise of hands
if that's okay.
How many of you experienced a Log4j event
that happened a couple of years ago?
More than half the room? Excellent.
How many of you were on the
frontline on MIM bridges?
Having to answer CISOs and CIOs
or CTOs, you know, around
exposure, blast radius.
Any of you on the frontline?
So 1, 2, 3. I can see a few hands.
How awesome was that experience?
I'm being sarcastic here,
but you get the drill, right?
It was chaotic. It was absolutely nuts.
Pardon my French here,
but it was insane, right?
And that's exactly what we
want to talk about today is
how can agentic AI help you
and your organization be better prepared
for situations like the Log4j event?
Everyone, I'm Praveen Bhat.
I'm a principal solutions
architect coming all the way
from Down Under or Australia
as we like to call it
and with me today, I have?
- [Justin] Hello, everyone,
I'm Justin Thomas.
I'm a senior cloud support engineer.
And I spend my days working
and helping customers
with cloud operations.
So the Log4j event Praveen just mentioned,
I was there at the frontline
and I was helping customers,
many customers simultaneously.
And what I witnessed was chaos.
It was organized chaos at scale.
And I would be on a call with a customer
and helping them trying to find exposure
and suddenly I will see five
more customers coming in
with the same problem, same questions.
So I want to take a look of an example
of the same experience.
So this is a fictitious company,
Manual Everything Corporation.
And imagine this Friday
afternoon, the team is ready
to wrap up for the week
and suddenly, an alarm is raised.
A critical CVE gets announced
and now thousands of the
instances needs Apache.
So an emergency bridge call is scheduled,
security director joins the call and ask,
"All right, everyone,
are we exposed or not?
Do we have exposure and
what's our blast radius?"
So first few minutes nobody
answered. It's silence.
The platform team hasn't
even joined the call, right?
And after some time
after we paged the platform team,
the platform engineer join, and says like,
I'm still trying to figure that out.
I need to log into the instances,
I need to log into the accounts,
see how much number
of instances are non-compliant right now.
And also I need to test this
patch that just released
before we start deploying
to the production.
The IT compliance manager jumps in,
asks, are we doing an
emergency patching right now
or can we do that?
Can we wait till a patch
maintenance window?
So the CTO of the company is listening
to all this conversation, is frustrated
because this looks like a
scavenger hunt for the right data
to make the decision
and which acknowledges that
we need better automation,
we need better intelligence.
This conversation is something
that I constantly see.
First 30 minutes to an
hour, we are just waiting.
We are waiting for the right
people to join the call
at the emergency bridge call.
And when the right people joins the call
it's the same questions.
These questions, which
instances are affected?
When are we doing the patch?
Do we need a downtime, right?
So imagine like this single
assessment, this conversation is
for single CVE and this
is going to be for hours.
Now imagine doing that for
multiple CVEs in a month.
The team simply cannot scale to do it.
And that's why
what if we add an intelligent agent
which work alongside with your engineers
to help identify and assess
these vulnerabilities,
check the compliance requirements
and also do the remediation?
So your team stays in control
but it's now augmented by these agents
to do all the heavy lifting.
And that's what we want to show you today,
the intelligent agents that we built.
And we can move to the demo.
The demo setup that we
have is pretty similar
to an enterprise setup.
So we have three different environment.
Dev, Staging and Prod.
Each environment has
different patch schedule
and also have different patch
compliance requirements.
The existing service
is already configured.
Amazon Inspector, AWS
Systems Manager, AWS Config,
these are the services
which are already detecting
your vulnerabilities
already remediating.
What's missing is a
intelligent orchestrator
that leads the way when a
critical CVE gets released.
That's where we add our
intelligent patch automation.
This is a multi-agent pattern
so there are four agents that we create.
One is supervisor
and which have control of
three specialist agents.
So these agents are built using Strands.
Now Strands is an open source SDK
that makes it easier
to build and run agents
with few lines of code.
And what it brings is a
model driven approach,
which means we allow the
LLMs to think on its own,
to think autonomously
and make decision to use the results.
And this is deployed in our account,
in our demo account using
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So AgentCore is an agent AI platform
which makes it easier to deploy
and operate AI agents at scale and safely.
Cool.
So I'll switch to the terminal now
and we can see the
patching in this automation
that we build in action.
- [Praveen] Folks, can
you see the font okay
and the back especially?
- [Justin] Yeah. Awesome. Thank you.
- [Praveen] Thank you.
- [Justin] Okay, so we call this Patchy,
that's the name that we
are given for the system,
the agentic system that we built.
And you can see we have access
to the specialist agents.
So first thing during a...
Okay, so what you're actually
seeing is a simple chat client
that we build to interact with the agent.
Naturally you'll build a
proper web app in production
which can even integrate
with your internal change
systems like Jira or ServiceNow.
But here we just want to
like show it like simply,
like how we can interact with the agent.
So chat client seems pretty simple.
Okay, so first thing,
during a critical event,
what I want to know is
understand the environment,
understand what's running
in my account, right?
So even the platform
engineer is taking some time
to log into the console,
log in like
what my production instances
protection environment looks like.
So ask the agent,
just to summarize, what's
there in my environment?
Okay, so I'm gonna ask it
to also give me the information
about the compliance requirements
for those production instances.
So what we are doing is we are interacting
with that supervisor agent that we saw
and it's making that necessary API calls.
It's reading the EC2 task,
it's creating the AWS Config service
and within seconds, we
have the complete picture
of your production environment, right?
In society, we get a common
configuration information
about the production,
but most importantly, we
see the compliance framework
for each in society
and that's useful information
for us to make the decision.
So at Manual Everything Operation,
if you see, these information are spread
across spreadsheets,
Excel sheets, CMDB tools
but here we got it with one prompt.
Now do you remember the
first question security director asked?
It was, are we exposed?
What's our exposure?
So let's ask the agent to find
if there is vulnerabilities
in our production environment.
I can just say prod. Cool.
So this time, the specialist agents,
the vulnerability analyst agent,
the supervisor consults that agent
and that's being built to use
to query the AWS inspector
to get these findings.
And imagine if you're a security
engineer, you would do that
by logging into the AWS Amazon Inspector,
download the findings,
check the CVE details,
check if there are patch
available for that CVEs,
then download everything,
get a priority list
and we are talking like
hours of work, right?
Here, within seconds, you will see,
exactly 37.6 seconds, you will see
that we got all those results.
So the agent summarizes
that there is 50 high
severity vulnerabilities
that's there in the production environment
and also summarizes the top critical CVEs
based on the CVSS score
and which instances are affected by it
and which compliance is at risk
if you don't pass these CVEs.
Now here comes the interesting question
which was asked by the IT
compliance manager is that
when is the right time
to patch this, right?
So there is an SLA
requirement of the company,
there's a patch manager window.
How do we come to a
decision when to patch this?
So I will ask the agent to come and see
and tell us like when is the
right time to patch this.
Also, I'm just,
if you notice I just write
when should we patch this?
I'm not specifying severity,
I'm not specifying vulnerabilities.
It's because like with AgentCore,
we are using AgentCore memory
which remembers all the
conversation history that we have
so it's a context aware agent
and we'll go through that
once we see the architecture.
But this time, like you see,
it's consulting the patch manager agent,
there's a specialist agent
and it's checking
what's our patch manager
window, what's our SLA.
And it gives you a decision,
like it says like patching
decision needed 24 days
until next window.
So your maintenance window
is 24 days from today, right?
And vulnerability status is,
okay, it actually says SLA data
unavailable for some reason.
Let's actually check again.
So the patch manager
agent, we'll see the code
and in the Strands, we give this,
the patch manager agent access to a tool
which can calculate the SLA requirement.
And when we ask this,
when should we patch,
it actually go and check
what's our SLA policies
for those specific se
and then see a delta with the
maintenance window, right?
Okay, so here it goes.
So it says emergency patching required,
there's an SLA violation.
So there is an SLA deadline
because your instances
are PCI-DSS requirement,
so you need to patch within 48 hours
but your maintenance
window is 24 days away,
so that's like, you are at risk, right?
So do the immediate
patching within 48 hours.
So that's the recommendation, right?
So the agents helped us
avoid an SLA violation
and gave a clear recommendation
that you need to patch this now.
So up until now we identify
which instance are affected,
which vulnerabilities are there,
and we came into a decision
that we need to do and apply.
We need to like do the patching now.
So let's ask the agent to do the patching,
but I want to like start with dev first.
We checked everything
for the prod right now,
but we need to like start with the dev
and then stating and the prod.
So just gonna ask,
okay, apply emergency patching
for the dev instances.
So this time, also the patch
manager agent will come
into picture which is built
to do all the systems manager API goals.
So in the patch manager you deploy,
you run a run command
and you use AWS-RunPatchBaseline document.
Okay, so it's actually asked me to clarify
which environment should I patch.
Okay, so let's patch the dev environment.
Yeah, so at the backend,
it's going to generate a run command ID.
It's going to target those dev instances,
the five dev instances
and it'll use AWS-RunPatchBaseline
document for that.
- [Praveen] Just if I
may add, Justin, please.
I think quite interesting
to know is the smartness
of a large language model
to be able to understand the fact
that you've been discussing
about production the whole time
and all of a sudden you're
saying you wanna swap,
you wanna switch to the dev environment,
actually trying to get a confirmation,
which in a lot of instances
doesn't really happen.
And again, it's something
that you'll notice the more memory,
the more context that the
large language model has,
the more aware it is about
your organization, your processes,
the better it becomes with such things.
- [Justin] Yeah, thank you.
So we can see like the
command ID is generated,
the status right now is pending.
So five dev instances are
affected, sorry, targeted.
So we do have some next
steps that provides
by the agent that we can check the status.
Also we can type "proceed"
to continue to the staging environment.
So basically agents understand
that this is a phase rollout.
So we started the dev.
I didn't specify this going
to be like staging a prod
so it understands that
if I type "proceed," it'll start
patching the staging environment next
or we can wait and check and verify
if everything's fine
and then we can do that.
So we avoided an SLA violation.
We did the emergency patching, right?
But what about the times
that we were not able
to catch that SLMS
and that's what the CTO
of Manually Everything
Cooperation is thinking right now.
How many times we were non-compliant
just because the team were busy
doing the scavenger hunt for the data?
And this is something even
the auditor's gonna ask,
what was your compliance history, right?
So Manual Everything Operation
does not have a tool to get this
so let's ask the agent to get,
how many times did we miss the SLA?
So this time, it's the
last specialist agent,
the compliance analyst agent
is consulted by the supervisor agent.
And what it does is it fetches
the reports from S3 bucket
and then do the math,
it checks when was the
vulnerability released,
when we did the patching
and also check the SLA policies.
Yeah, so it actually checks the SLA policy
and see like how many times
did we did the patching,
which should be like done
within the SLA timeline.
So it says there are total six
breaches in the last 30 days
and also gives the breach details,
like these were the CVE
IDs that were like breached
and these were the team
that were affected by it.
Okay, so...
Yeah, so next we want to like
explore the architecture.
We want to explore how we build this goal
and how we come to like
the decision principle
that we took when we were building this
and for this I will hand over to Praveen.
- [Praveen] Awesome, thanks Justin.
Couple of things that
will kind of highlight
as we get into the code
is the patch manager
or the patch manager agent
itself has the ability
to verify or do health checks
as part of its patching process as well.
So the reason why we can't do it
and just in the interest of time,
but under the hood it's basically
checking your application,
your infrastructure and
we'll go into detail
of how it actually does it.
And once it completes its patching,
it's uploading all that
information into an S3 bucket
as Justin kind of pointed out.
All right, now that we've
seen the solution in action,
let's have a look at the
underlying architecture
and code that drives the solution.
As you've already noticed,
we've got multiple agents in the mix.
This is based on a pattern
called a supervisor pattern
wherein you've got a supervisor agent
that manages the end-to-end orchestration
of the whole workflow
while it consults or coordinates
with specialized agents,
each of which have a specialized
role, set of instructions,
a set of tools that it can use
to be able to complete a given task.
Now you might all know this,
agents by themselves
don't have the ability
to understand the user
intent, cannot reason.
And for that intent, we
have Claude Sonnet 4.5
as a large language model
running on Amazon Bedrock
that gives it the brainpower.
Now even with all the brainpower,
the agents need to be able
to interact with AWS services.
For that, we have specialized tools
that are exposed to
the specialized agents.
Justin's mentioned this, but very quickly,
in terms of the AWS services, we have
in the mix are Amazon Inspector
for vulnerability findings,
AWS Config to give the
agents an understanding
of the resource dependencies.
So when it actually makes
a patching decision,
it understands the business criticality
that might have an impact
on the whole patching operation, right?
If it's let's say a web app,
a frontend facing application
that has extremely high business impact,
you don't want to do it
or you don't probably
wanna patch it, right?
So all that decision is factored in
by the patch manager agent.
This in your case could
be something like a CMDB
like a ServiceNow or a
Jira that you're using.
But anything that is able
to give the resource dependency view,
the large language model
will absorb that information
and make it available for
the decision making process.
Systems manager to understand
the patch compliance state
to apply the patches.
And then you've got S3
to store and retrieve
the compliance reports.
And finally EC2 to apply
the patches themselves.
We are using Strands SDK,
Justin's mentioned this,
but the one thing I wanna highlight
why Strands is for one key reason.
Strands makes it very easy for users
to be able to build agents
that can interact in a continuous manner
with the large language
model and the tools
in what's referred to as an agentic loop.
What that means is think of a scenario
where a user puts in a request.
Alright, patch my instances
in dev environment.
The agents don't understand it
so they've gotta understand the intent.
This request gets routed to
the large language model.
The model says alright,
I understand the intent
but I need access to tools
that can interact with AWS services.
So the request gets routed to the tools,
the tools go talk to
the relevant services,
come back with a response.
That response is fed back
to the large language model.
It reasons that and goes on and on and on
until the user's original
request is completed.
Now all of this happens within
what's called an agentic loop.
You don't need to code it.
It's just made available to you
and I'll show you when we
get to the code itself.
And very quickly in terms of scale
and security, it was super easy for us
to just deploy onto AgentCore.
AgentCore comes with seven perimeters,
if I'm not wrong, six to seven,
but we are only using three of those.
Runtime to actually
host and run our agents,
memory for making the
agents context aware,
and finally observability
to be able to understand
the state of our agents
by using tracing, metrics, logs.
All of which are very, very useful
when you're trying to debug a situation,
when you're trying to iterate
or evaluate your prompts,
you're making changes
to your large language
model parameters, et cetera.
All of that, observability
makes it super easy
for you to get that information.
And that's it.
Now, when Justin and I
came up with this idea,
this is like four months ago,
we didn't start with this whole idea
and like this sort of architecture at all.
We thought we'll start off
with something super basic, super simple,
understand the capabilities
of large language model,
understand what enterprise
users would prefer
in this capability.
So we thought we'll start off pretty small
and then we continue to iterate,
get feedback from customers
and then iterate again and
then again and again and again.
So we thought in the next 30 odd minutes
that we have left, we'll
kind of take you all
on that accelerated experience
of how we started off
with something very basic
and then how we iterated
and how we got to the stage
where Patchy is today.
So hopefully you can
leverage, you know, the tips
and practices that we followed,
the architecture patterns
to get you and your teams
to a stage where you are more comfortable
to be able to handle the Log4j event.
Sounds okay? Cool.
I'm gonna swap quickly to my demo screen.
All right. Excellent.
Okay.
So what we started off
with first was a super simple EC2 agent
that could just list
all your EC2 instances,
to get the compliance state, right?
So let's just start off with that. Okay.
If it's okay, I'm just
gonna get rid of the screen,
and make this a little bit on the left.
Yeah, perfect. Can you see okay?
All right, so I'm gonna start off
with importing of some main class.
So the agent class is the main class
because it's the core interface
into your large language model
for your conversation
management and all of that.
So this is the most
important class that you need
and then for your agent to be able to...
Wow, I'm a terrible typist.
For your agents to be able to interact
with your AWS services, you need a tool
and Strands has this built
in tool called use_aws
that's available with the Strands library.
And then I'm gonna just
quickly define the agent.
Start off with a name.
Yes, agents have their own identity now.
And then give it a system prompt.
System prompt is where you
specify the role, the persona,
the traits, the instructions
that you want your agent to have.
In our case, I'm gonna
keep it very simple.
"You are an EC2 assistant," that's it.
And finally don't forget the tools.
You are gonna say use_aws which is a tool
that allows the agent to
interact with AWS services.
That's it.
Six to seven lines of code within Strands
that allows your agent
to be able to interact
with the EC2 services
in your account, get the
list of EC2 instances,
and then interact with systems manager
to get the compliance state.
That's it.
So I'm gonna quickly start off,
I'm gonna say, "List all
my EC2 instances in prod
and their compliance state in us-east-1."
That's it. I'm gonna run this.
Alright, Python.
So hopefully I didn't make a typo. Yeah.
So what you're seeing
at the very top is,
I'll help you list all your EC2 instances.
That's a large language model
actually understanding the user intent
and it's figured out that
it needs to do a few things,
which is get the EC2 instances,
then get the compliance state.
And then you see the tool invocation,
the response that comes back.
The intent is being reasoned
by the large language model
and goes on and on, right?
So you'll see multiple
tool invocations happening
and then it comes up
with the final response
which is like here are all
your production instances,
are they noncompliant, compliant?
And a bunch of other information
that I probably didn't need.
But anyways, this is just
a basic agent, right?
What I do wanna highlight
is the agentic loop again.
The large language invoked
the tool, got the response,
and as you can see here,
I don't know if the highlight is working,
but the InvalidParameterValueException.
And we've reached a stage
where large language models
can auto correct themselves,
figure out that the syntax
that it followed was wrong,
goes back to its knowledge base,
figure out what's the
right in intent in syntax
and submits that again
and it probably tries AWS Config.
There you go.
Because we said compliance
state, it goes to config
for some reason to get
the compliance information
and then figures out
config doesn't have it
and then autocorrects itself
and tries to get that
information from systems manager,
which is here somewhere.
Yeah, I'll use the systems
manager compliance API to get it.
So that was it.
So we realized like we can do a lot,
but the performance was not optimum.
The fact that we had to go five
tool invocations sometimes,
sometimes seven, it wasn't ideal.
So we thought
how about we make the agent
more richer, more powerful,
give it more tools and
tweak our system prompt.
So at this point in time, we
went with something like this
which had, just gonna remove this,
the same agent but with
slightly more enriched prompt
and better tools that it has access to.
And I explained to you a bit more
of what's happening under the hood.
So you got Bedrock model defined.
When we didn't define one with Strands,
by default it uses Claude
Sonnet 4 today in us-east-1
and also sets up all the
parameters like Temperature, Top P,
which controls creativity
and a few other things
like max tokens as well.
It has default parameters
which might not be
suitable for our use case
so we had to control that as well.
And in our case, we just tried like,
can you use Nova which gives
us better cost of performance
to see how it works.
So this was a second iteration.
Literally, this was it.
And then control the temperature element
to control the creativity
of the large language model
to make it as deterministic as possible.
Now for all the Python aficionados,
you can see the tools here.
I've got two tools.
One, to get the EC2 instances
and another to get the
patch compliance state.
It's just a Python
function leveraging boto3.
That's all it is.
The only difference is the fact
that we use a tool decorator,
which exposes a Python
function to be used as a tool
by the large language model.
And the way it does it
is by the docstrings.
The docstrings, as long as
you're clear and structured
in terms of what the tool does,
it knows when and how to use it.
So in this case you just say,
"Get EC2 instances optionally
filtered by environment,"
and so on.
That's all it is.
And same thing with the patch compliance,
we're doing the same
thing here as well, right?
So that's the tool bit.
Now coming to the prompt,
previously we saw just the EC2 instance.
I wanted to change that
because you could see all
that additional information coming through
which we didn't need.
So you could control that
using what's like a behavior
which are basically set of instructions
that I'm giving to the agent
to ensure that it follows a
few things that I wanted to
which is like give me the exact summary
sort of to begin with
and then the details,
markdown tables for multiple instances,
use the default region
if it's not mentioned,
but here comes interesting bit.
I'm building an EC2 assistant,
I don't want anything else.
So you can control the scope and the role
that it needs to perform
using a prompt, right?
In this case, I've just said
if user asked anything
about non-EC2 related queries,
just respond with saying,
"I only handle it."
Simple as that.
And then being explicit with your tools,
again, you don't need to,
it's a personal preference
because the docstring itself
help the large language model understand
when it should use the tool,
but I'm just pedantic.
I prefer it to be very explicit,
make sure the agent understand
what it needs to do.
And then the output format,
we're using a chatbot on a terminal
so had to follow certain
set of instructions
from an output point of view.
And then the tools,
as you can see we're not
using use_aws anymore.
We just have two tools.
I've got a very basic why loop.
Just to start thinking
about a chatbot experience
and that's all it is.
Alright, so let's invoke this one.
Let's say, clear, yeah, python EC2
but with tools.
Comes with the request,
so I am going to copy paste
my previous prompt itself
so you can see exactly the behavior
but this time with a more smarter agent.
So you'll see the streaming information,
what's coming through
and this is one of the
reasons why we built a chatbot
on terminal just to show
you the streaming behavior.
We probably could have
done this with a web app,
but it was just a bit more
easier with the chatbot.
So you can see it figures out the intent
and it makes only two tool calls.
That's it.
If you remember,
actually before I go, just
observe this behavior as well.
This is quite important.
The fact that it just sort
of types one line at a time
and I'll just explain what's
happening under the hood
and our experience, why this is not ideal.
It just had two tool calls.
If you remember, the
previous agent did five.
Sometimes there's seven,
sometimes two. It's unpredictable.
With tools, you start getting
more predictable deterministic behaviors.
Now to the point again of that
single line being printed,
that's because the tool that we had
for patch compliance state only allowed
for one instance at a time.
So the large language model
is basically making five,
there's five instances, yeah,
five API calls to systems
manager to get that information.
Not ideal.
Patching is the way to go,
but we realized that the hard way.
Not the hard way, it's just
I think we were being lazy.
Actually one last thing around the scope.
List all my lambda instances.
Now if you remember, this
is just an EC2 agent.
It shouldn't give me any information.
So from a security point of
view, I can build in guardrails.
It's just one way to do it.
There are other ways as well.
Probably some things that are more harder
but this is one way to
actually achieve it,
especially when it comes to injecting,
for lack of a better term, I'll say crap
into your prompt as well.
So this is one way to actually achieve it,
is having controls in place
within your prompt itself.
Within your system prompt, sorry.
So it just says I only
handle EC2 related queries.
Ignore the duplication,
but it's just saying, I only
handle EC2 related queries
and the same would apply
if you keep trying.
So that's it.
So we reached a stage
where we realized, okay,
we're able to do a lot more
with use_aws so we started
building more tools.
But the agents started
getting heavier and heavier.
So we got to a stage
where it started becoming
monolith versus microservice
sort of debate again.
Should we go with a single agent
or should we start splitting
into multiple agents?
And the reason why it
was becoming more obvious
for us to go down the latter part was
because of the hallucination confusion.
So simple sort of philosophy
we started following was
if an agent is not doing
one specialized task,
then it should be broken up, right?
So again, it's a philosophical debate.
Again, monolith versus
microservices, not gonna get into it.
I'm pretty sure we're gonna
spend all day, maybe all week
on it, but we are not gonna get anywhere.
But the reality was for us,
we started getting better
results by breaking it down
and evolving it and adding more tools.
We got to a stage where Patchy today
and I'll just walk you through
the Patchy codebase now.
Alright, I'm just gonna
close these things.
I'll close this as well.
So just very quickly
in terms of the project structure,
all of the agent related code is
within the agent folder itself.
We have a helper function
within the helper folders
and I'll walk you through that as well.
But just very quickly, the
bedrock_agentcore.yaml file
that you're seeing in the docker file,
these are pertaining to
the AgentCore deployment.
So they're the configuration
file in the docker file
that's used by the runtime
to be able to deploy agents.
Everything else, which is the four agents.
You've got the patch manager, supervisor,
vulnerability agent and
compliance analyst, right?
Super simple.
In the helper functions, very simple ones.
We just have memory, globals
and a few other things.
But the key thing I wanna
highlight is the tools file.
So you can either have the tools embedded
within your agents,
but the fact
that I come from a software
engineering background,
it was easier for me to just externalize
and have it all in a separate file.
It just made it easy for
maintainability and reliability
and few things and you can
always import it, right,
as simple as that.
So I've already walked
you through a few tools.
I'm not gonna bore you with that again.
I just wanna show you one tool
and just what does good look like
from our perspective, I guess.
So we've gotta get
vulnerability findings here.
I'm gonna just remove this so
you can see the whole screen.
Again, tool decorator.
But there's probably two, three key things
that I wanna highlight here
is one, the docstrings.
Again, if you have been
running Python code,
you're familiar with this,
but being as clear and
structured as possible makes it
that much better for large language models
to be able to understand
when and how to use it all.
It's garbage in, garbage
out. It's as simple as that.
So in our case, we define
what the purpose is,
the arguments, the CVE ID,
severity, environment, limit.
For example, being very clear
in terms of the default values,
giving examples where possible
and what it returns
once the tool's invoked.
Try and return dictionary
objects where possible.
The more context
that the large language model has compared
to say just a string
output, the better it'll be
in terms of providing you
with more richer information
as an output, okay?
Now one thing I do wanna highlight,
this is probably my second thing
or third thing, I can't remember,
is the fact that you have
optional and required
or mandatory arguments.
You can basically control the behavior
of agents using this one thing.
To give you an example,
let's just say you get
vulnerability findings,
if my severity was mandatory or required.
When the large language model is invoked,
so let's say Justin in his prompt says,
give me all the vulnerabilities
and that's it.
He just says give me all vulnerabilities.
He's not mentioned the severity at all.
At that point in time
if this was required or mandatory,
the large language model,
rather than assuming
that, hey the user is
asking me for all of it
so he probably assumes, they assume
that it is critical,
'cause critical is high,
so I'll just go with
the critical findings.
There's an assumption being baked
into the large language model.
However, if you enforce it
then the large language
model will question
or check with the user again
to say, do you mean
critical, high, medium, low?
So you can control the behavior
using just the argument itself.
Other than that, it's not
rocket science, right?
It's a simple Python function.
We're using boto3 clients to be able
to get that information
for vulnerability findings.
That's it.
Alright, moving on to supervisor.
I'm just gonna have a
quick look at the time.
Okay, we're good on time.
So this is the supervisor
agent that we have,
basically the one that controls
the entire orchestration
for the workflow.
Now for the supervisor
to be able to interact
with the agents,
we're using a pattern called agents tool.
If I scroll all the way down,
you'll start seeing what I mean.
Actually I'll just mention
one thing very quickly.
So here it is.
So you'll see these three lines.
We're importing the three key agents
from the different files
that they belong to
and we're making them available as tools
by using the tool decorator.
So I'm gonna scroll down
very quickly. Here it is.
So this is just the consult
vulnerability analyst,
which is the agent itself,
the specialized agent.
We just parsed the large language
sorry, the natural language request in
as a string allowing the
vulnerability analyst
to be able to understand
the intent of the user.
So all the supervisor agent is doing
is understanding the
intent, passing that request
onto the specialized agent
based on their capabilities
and I'll walk you through that as well
and then let the specialized
agents do the rest.
That's it.
So in this case, we've
just got the three tools.
We are also using the use_aws tool
if in case a request is outside the scope
of any of these three agents.
So I'll walk you
through very quickly the
system prompt itself here.
You're defining what the role is
which is a patch automation
coordinator routing request
to the specialized agents.
And I have some response
guidelines in terms of
what are the things it needs to follow
like verbosity in terms of
the output, being very direct,
what we actually need, what
format do we need it in
instead of pagination, truncating the data
if it's more than, you know, 10
as you might have seen said
50 severities available
but only showing 10 for example
and those kind of things.
And then the routing priority.
How do I want the priority to be?
How do I want the request to be routed,
which is understanding
the user's primary intent.
If it can't find that information,
go to the context from the memory itself
and if you can't find that as
well then route to use_aws.
That's it.
I just provide the details around
when to use the specialized agents,
which is analyze security,
vulnerability, CVEs,
et cetera, et cetera.
So you can use semantic
routing, keyword routing
or capability based routing as well.
So this is just one way we could do it.
And that's it.
We mentioned the tools again.
Now if you recall in the
second agent from memory
when the tools started printing
out one line at a time,
this is what I was trying to get to.
With tools that you've defined,
you can control patching, right?
So if you've got an API call
that has to be made 10 times, 20 times,
then you can control it.
But something like use_aws,
which is a built-in tool,
you can't control it.
So you're using the prompt itself
to be able to control the
large language model's behavior
of how it should use
or leverage that tool.
So in this case, patching related queries,
using filters to reduce data transfer,
this all helped in reducing
the token consumption.
Yes, we have to pay for tokens
and we realized that again
as the cost started going up.
And that's it.
It was just output format like
you know, emojis, et cetera
to make it look appealing
but that was it.
That's the supervisor agent,
like just to give you an overview.
I'll show you patch manager very quickly
because that's the most complex one
and every other specialized agent
follows the same sort of format.
As you can see, we've got a whole heap
of helper tools available.
It's just because we wanted
very specific capabilities
to come out of it.
We want it to be deterministic,
we want it to be consistent.
So just walking you through it,
we define the scope very clearly
because what we observed was
when the scope wasn't defined
and you might have observed this as well.
The supervisor agent,
when a request comes through,
routes it to multiple agents.
If a specialized agent is not
able to perform the set task
and it's because it's not
in its scope, it comes back
with an outer scope response
and the supervisor agent
now needs to correct itself
and figure out which other special agent
that it needs to route the request to.
So this was extremely important
and something you might
want to keep in mind.
As you might all appreciate,
patching as a process
is extremely rigorous.
It is very controlled.
You don't want it to just
be done in a hillbilly way.
You want to control that whole form.
So when we started off,
patch manager was doing things in PADL
when it shouldn't,
like it was trying to do dev staging,
at the same time trying
to be more efficient
but we realized that that's
not the way it should be.
So we had to bake in this concept
of workflow within the prompt
to control its behavior.
So the way we kind
of started it off was like
get the CVE severity first.
So either the user provides that
in the prompt itself saying,
hey, give me the critical
severity in the dev environment
and if that's not available,
if it's available in the memory,
extract it from there as well.
So it has different ways
that it can actually
absorb that information
and use that for its calculation
and we'll get to that in in a minute.
Then get the patch compliance.
So we have multiple applications
running within these instances,
each assigned a compliance framework
that has an SLA associated with it.
So get the patch compliance
state based on the environment
and the severity that's been provided.
Now the next step is to
get the maintenance window
for the said environment,
which is when is the next execution
from a patching perspective gonna happen.
Now comes the smart
decision making ability
of the patch manager agent here.
Now that it has the severity information,
understands the SLA of your application,
it needs to make a decision on
if it has to patch it
in an emergency form,
which is straightaway
or can it wait for the
next maintenance window.
That all happens with
just a few lines of code
rather than a pretty large FL statement
that would've probably written too complex
for anybody to understand.
And that's it.
And then just display that information
which is, hey, window is within
or beyond the SLA deadline,
so we need to either patch
it now or leave it for later.
That was it.
So that whole workflow
was baked into the prompt.
Could we have optimized it? Absolutely.
But we reached this stage
based on a lot of tests.
Last week, we had a release
as we're getting closer to re:Invent,
we're actually in re:Invent already,
but there's a lot of new announcements.
So one new announcement was Strands SOP
or standard operating procedure
wherein a lot of the workflow
sort of implementations
can actually be externalized,
which makes the prompt a lot more smaller,
which means less token consumption,
more faster larger language,
more faster agent responses.
All right, then comes
the instance ranking,
so it's done the calculation
on emergency versus not emergency.
It also has the ability
to rank your instances
based on business impact
and blast radius
and then actually go
through a phase execution.
This would've taken a long time,
hence we can show them the demo
as I mentioned that previously.
But under the hood it has awareness
that it needs to go in a phased manner
even if it's an emergency
patching situation.
And it does that, keeping in mind
that health verification
is extremely important,
which is mandatory after each environment.
We've all observed this
when you patch applications,
you know, experience something
and they just go down impacting
your uptime, et cetera.
So we kind
of built a very simple
health verification system.
You could build a more
complex one obviously,
but the logic is the same.
We got two layers of checks.
One is a simple ping check with SSM,
which is for the infrastructure layer.
The second one is for CloudWatch alarms.
Now in your case, you
could integrate your agents
as a webhook with Splunk,
New Relic, Datadog,
whatever you use
to see if any alarms have been triggered
as part of the patch.
And if it does happen, it can roll back.
How useful would that experience be
where you can just roll
back capacity to apply
because it's broken a system?
And it's also smart enough to figure out
that it only rolls back that environment
so that you can compare a delta
between a previous or a lower environment
that you patched was successful compared
to this environment as well.
And finally, all this
information needs to go somewhere
for compliance reporting to a CTO is happy
and that happens with a specific tool
and all that information.
And that's it.
We have rollback policy output format,
but this is pretty straightforward.
Couple of things I want you all
to take away from a prompt perspective.
I'm sure you've all experienced this.
As much as I wanna say
prompt engineering is an art,
it feels like there's a lot
of science behind it now.
Few key tips that have
helped us is keep them
as structured and clear as possible.
Keep them concise.
The more verbose they are...
Every time the agent
actually like is working
with your specialist agents,
they are taking a lot
of this with it.
Makes it really hard,
becomes more expensive.
And keep in mind
that you don't have
conflicting instructions
at the top and the bottom, right?
It's happened a few times
when you've said something
at the top and the bottom
is completely different.
Agent's confused quite
easily in that regard.
Exemplify, show them an
example of what good looks like
so that they use that as
a pattern moving forward.
Yeah, that's pretty much what we had
in terms of the code itself.
What I'm gonna do very quickly is...
That's all. I think I had it, yes.
Can I just change that to PPT?
I think we've all seen,
like Justin's already shown the demo,
I've gone through the codebase with you
and look, if you have
time, we're more than happy
to take questions either
offline depending on
how easy it's gonna be on us
but we are happy to take questions
or just go out of the room
and answer any questions.
But we've just seen
how agentic AI can help you,
Manual Everything Corporation
be better prepared, right?
It's technically and operationally viable.
It's not if, it's just a matter of when.
I'm not saying it'll just like
magically solve it tomorrow
but I think we're very, very close
to a stage where answering questions
for the security director
of what's the risk of blast radius,
that was just done in seconds, right?
You no longer are dependent
on application owners
and application teams to
give you that information.
You can get that within
a matter of seconds.
Platform engineers now have the confidence
and the comfort knowing
that if they apply a patch,
they can roll that back.
This is especially useful
in a centralized environment
where you have application teams,
platform engineering teams,
cloud teams, et cetera.
Super useful.
Compliance managers are feeling a bit more
at ease knowing that they don't need
to rush through a critical
vulnerability just
because it's critical.
If it fits within the maintenance window,
they can make that decision sooner.
And the CTO is super happy
that they're not gonna be in the press
because they're more compliant.
They understand the
health of their business
from a patching perspective.
And they can continue
to help the teams evolve
and get better.
So if there's three key things
that we want you to take away
are these three things here.
Tools versus prompts.
I think we get to a stage where,
again, it's getting a
bit more philosophical,
but what we've experienced is
tools is more deterministic,
more consistent.
Prompts is more creative.
It lets the large language
model think on its own.
It works sometimes, it
doesn't work sometimes.
So keep that in mind
when you're trying to build a particular,
when you're trying to
get to a certain outcome.
Think about it
when you think about tools versus prompts.
Augment over replace.
I think a lot of people
think like AI is just gonna,
and this is a controversial statement now,
I think AI is gonna take over the world.
I think it will eventually.
We're not at a stage there yet.
Whatever we've shown you today is showing
augmenting capabilities of an AI
to make your teams, make
your systems more smarter,
and more powerful.
So they're meant
to augment over replace
your existing systems.
Agents will give you
the scale, the agility
but they need humans to provide
the governance and oversight
without which it's gonna
be a really bad situation
for all of us.
And finally, build
small, test and iterate.
We didn't get there on day one.
We've taken a few months to get here.
Again, we've got our day jobs
but I'm sure if we had put our
mind in just like you would,
you can accelerate through
the whole experience
but start small, test and iterate.
Use your observability
tooling to get to a stage
where you understand what it can do,
what the responses look like
before you tweak it, right?
Take your time.
And one key thing, if I
could highlight here is
even if you're not a software engineer,
please follow all the
software engineering practice
in terms of version control.
Look at tools that help
you with model evaluation,
prompt evaluation as you
tweak your prompts and models.
The parameters, they're super useful.
We are planning to publish the code soon,
but whatever we've built
has been based on patterns
and samples that are easily available.
So these are the QR codes
for Bedrock AgentCore
samples and Strands agent.
Hopefully, we'll have
our code published soon.
But in the meantime you can try
and take the lessons you've
learned today, hopefully
in terms of the patterns,
the architecture principles,
and apply them with these samples.
And everyone's here for
swag, I'm pretty sure.
If you're not, you can come for the demos,
we'll be there as well.
But please do visit the Cloud
Ops kiosk at the AWS Village.
But yeah, on Justin and my behalf,
thank you so much.
We do have five minutes, so
we're happy to come around
and take questions if
that's okay with Diggy.
But yeah, thank you so much.
We really appreciate it.
- [Justin] Thank you.
(audience clapping)